dans la transaction s'il vous plaît les
passagers du vol air france
numéro 320 à destination de marrakech
sont informés et ceci afin d'éviter
désormais tout à l'entente du que le
texte qui va leur être présentées
maintenant et d'inspiration anti raciste
merci marrakech
ça nous a déçus natha nous a pas plu
c'est plein de table
pourtant le nourrain habite vers clichy
et là il y en a des arabes à mai à
marrakech
y'a que ça non déjà l'avion pour y aller
ça nous avait pas fait bonne impression
c'est pas ta la question de la violence
l avion comme lionel nallet un congrès
de l'entreprise il avait plutôt bien
fait et charlie un petit avion ring pour
nous et les collègues de l'entreprise
bien aucune premier suite est bien mais
c'est qu'un tas de vue arriver
l'aviateur ou quel malheur vous n'avez
pas qu'est ce qui vous avait trouvé
comme agathe heures eh bien je dis à ma
moitié ça commence bien
ma pauvre simone dans quoi qu'on sait
encore embarqué qu'elles ont et la
callas rap très à l'aise pas gêné du
tout du tout - arabe
je me suis dit faisons tout petits dés
fois qu'on marchait pas et je pars c'est
géraud de base c'est à dire et je veux
pas vad
c'est moi que je suis une bête à bord
visible un peu les gars là je tripote
les manettes et les petits boutons comme
si j'aurais fait ça depuis toujours
comme ceux de mes ancêtres personne
n'aurait jamais gardé une chèvre de
famille
ils ont pris à tulle ou en lien avec les
collègues qu'on me faisait pas on est
des touristes le comedd incident il
roulait à mettre benoît ouled nous
souhaite la bienvenue à bord très bien
parfait c'est pas le faire des remarques
l'armée française n'a qu'a fait un seul
quart à ces plumages dit à monsieur
cadori qui était à côté à voir comment
avec le service venerque en guise de dot
s et de bonbons ils vont nous envoyer
une gamme d olive de cacahuètes
la [ __ ] mais sûrement quelque chose de
pas catholique à la note est surpris en
d'ailleurs c'est l'autre la l'aviator
arabe lui même qui nous a demandé de les
attacher il ce qu'elle tombe
mesdames et messieurs vous êtes priés
d'attaché vos ceintures et des tonnes de
cigarettes en garde
je sais pas s'il a senti dans cet
appareil mieux sur de réprobation ou
quoi n'empêche que plein de tout le
voyage les incidents n'ont pas cessé de
se multiplier
monsieur cadeau rêvé qu'il a fini comme
a volontairement pendant s'exacerber
déjà oui au fait est ce que quelqu'un
parmi les passagers qui pourraient me
passer un big palaze à la fin que je
fasse mes calculs sinon on peut pas
décoller ça fait sérieux
moi j'avais mon waterman a plu même
corps pour les plaqués or que simone m'a
offert pour ma nomination à la direction
du service réclamation de la maison
oxygène amd fils pas du tout comme les
autres au ps et que les écrits de droite
à gauche reçoit terme un niveau
complètement salle au pire comme si vous
leur âme quand ils volent pas trop
comment elle le prétend après que soi
disant ils auraient été égarés votre
waterman la plume coffret cadeau tu
rigole oui mais oui travailleurs les
connais moi c'est ce monsieur l'a
finalement c'est monsieur k d'or et il
s'est dévoué qui a passé sur ce stylo
mid et nous irons plus nous sommes
volées mais tout le seigneur ce matin et
pendant toute la traversée il a pas
arrêté de se faire remarquer un moment
c'était un peu assoupie avec les
collègues mais l'intense chaleur qui
réunit dans la carlingue et les nerfs
qui commençait sur la chaîne info mon
ami on est tous très bien sûr société
encore lui lot l'indigène qui criait
saint soit honnête je lève où ça sent le
brûlé
les hommes ont voyagé dans ces
conditions la touche a reniflé comme des
cockers dans la travée dit tout bas
monsieur k d'oreilles s'amuse avec nous
quoi j'ai adoré très fin psychologue me
dit il s'amuse très bien parfait
amusons-nous la france est à quatre
pattes
j'ai tout à fait dans le sens de
l'histoire le maréchal lyautey et moi
nous nous inclinons est juste à quoi il
se met à hurler dans son micro comme un
hystérique
alors là tout est comme toi oh lalala
bout du compte le voulez vous me dire où
je me dis no 6 au plus je n'en ai pas la
moindre idée d'installer 10h02 coup
j'étais au board pour les deux la mienne
la simone était pas non plus très belle
à voir
ah bah dites vous rendez coup jeudi
bouge pas six mois ne pousse pas de
petit match et la coppa les cas
responsable n'importe quel terminal si
l'avion tome 7 à 10 ans de leur tarde
cela finit pas se poser c'est déjà
quelque chose
earl a partout des arabes des arabes d
arak que ça que sa caisse à les porter
bon ça normal
les douaniers et les policiers à quoi
voir la vie une fois aux actualités sas
prime très correctement il a l'air de
très bonne famille avec nationale
oui ils sont chez eux ils commis le
moins l'autre là le roi il est pas mal
ce garçon il est pas mal attention il
obtient la dragée haute à tous ces va nu
pieds je me demande s'il a peint peu de
sam francis collard quoi qu'il en soit
jeudi à simone c'est la dernière fois
qu'on met les pieds en colonie il faut
pas me dira si c'était à nous dans
l'entreprise nous employons énormément
de travail en or africain et bien que
les avons laissé installer leur village
leur espèce de bidonvilles n'a tout
bonnement chantier le fonds des poules
de pouvoir de la maison monsieur
bourdieu qui est un homme très libéral
plutôt à gauche arrivait un jour au
bureau complètement retourné en usage
vient de passer en voiture près des
baraques on aura fric 1 il faut
absolument faire quelque chose pour ces
malheureux ne pouvons pas tolérer une
pareille misère en plus ça se voit de la
route
c'est très fâcheuses pour le standing de
la maison eh bien nous nous sommes
réunis en comité nous avons voté des
crédits
croyez moi vous pouvez passer en voiture
près de chez nous vous verrez plus rien
de tout ça ils ont fait construire un
mur